うん それからもうそれもうほとんど最後のセクションになりますけど
心のケアですね  この悪循環ね
理性の悪循環をやめなくちゃいけないんですね
で あの最初に言ったでしょ
心は焦っているんだと
そこに問題が起こるんですよ
瞬時認識しなくちゃいけないんだから
まぶた閉じる以前に何やと認識しなくちゃいけないんです
それは法則なんですよ
そこで焦るんですよ だから落ち着いてれば落ち着きなんですよ
落ち着きでウッダキ 情動がなくなります
データが心に取り入れます
その場合は瞬時に認識できなくてはいいんじゃないんですか？もっとデータを入れて気楽にあ
こういうことだと あれ
赤く見えたんだから花じゃないかなとかね
こんなくだらんことをやらなくても
もう一回見ればいいでしょうに
ちゃんと だから落ち着いてる人は別に
じゃあもう一回見ますと
関連の情報を無作為に
何だっけ？無作為につなぐことがなくなります
だから落ち着いちゃうと
何でもいいんだからって言って
適当に何とか感情で合成することはしないんです
だから心のケアってそんな大したことじゃない
落ち着くだけでかなりうまくいくんですよ
判断が遅くても 理解が遅くても構わないんです
その間でデータ取ってますから
現実離れしてないんです
あのループは後で作るだけの話ですよ
落ち着いてデータを取り入れるんです
すぐわからなくてもいいんです
例えば数学の授業ですぐわかる人のことは先生が好きなんですけど
でもアホでない限りね
まあ性格いろいろありますよ
ちゃんと丁寧に これでこれでこれでこれでこうなるんだよと
ちょっと他の学生よりはちょっとちょこっと時間をかけて教えたら
そこでわかる子もいますよ
それで頭悪いっていうことわけになりません
仏教はそういう 理解するために時間がかかるかかからないかっていうことを決して問題にしてないんです
焦っていることがね 一回聞いたらわからない人は回ぐらい聞いてみても構いません
回聞く場合でもデータちゃんと入れてるでしょうに
現実離れになってないでしょうに
必ずしも瞬時に認識して知識として判断しなくても良い
瞬間で判断しなくてもいいんです
仏教は判断理解に時間がかかる性格の人もいることと
それが問題にならないことを認めてやります
あの人格分析の場合は
あの鋭い人と鈍い人は二タイプあるんだと
で 心の分析にいつでもこのアサンカーリカ
ササンカーリカと二つあるし
いつでもツーセットですよ
例えば欲の心が生まれる場合は
もうセット二つ アサンカーリカ
ササンカーリカというんですけどね
で それからまあ喜んでいるか
一般的でいるかということで
嫌があるかないか それでになりますけど
しかし分析は二つ二つになっていて
あの本に書いてますから読んでみてください
だからいつでも心はそういう二つのセットにしているんです
それから禅定を作る場合は瞑想して
色界の禅定 無色界の禅定
それから出世間的な悟りの禅定ってあるでしょうね
あれって瞬時には起こりませんだからね
結構頑張って頑張ってデータ入れて入れて入れて入れて入れている過程で
パッと生まれます それは早い人は遅い人はいます
それは決して問題ではありません
瞬間で出す間違った感情的な判断が 1億よりゆっくり達した正しい判断は優れていますからね
テキパキと判断する人っていうのはものすごい間違ってますからね
それよりは まあゆっくり考えて落ち着いて
あ こういうことにしますと決めた方がいいんです
これがあの まあ心の際なんですよ
速さではなく正確ということ Accuracy
is better than quickness. ただ早いのは知恵の証拠にはなりません
落ち着きです 冷静さですよ
知恵っていうのは 無作為に複数の不適切な判断を瞬時にする人も
時間かかっても判断に達しない人も
両方は無知です まあ瞬時に判断して終わっているというのは
これは無知なんです 裁判官はもう警察がね
もうなんていうか 被告人持った
じゃああんた有罪だよと決めるようなことだから
アホでしょうに それではなくて
訴えは何なのか 証拠は何なのか
実際証拠をこの人はそれやったのかとかね
そこで時間かけて裁判官は判決を出すでしょうね
それでもその判決に対して上告するでしょ
だから裁判官の判断のごとく
よく調べてゆっくり判断した方がいいんです
ただ単に早いっていうのは無知です
まあ早い人が正しければ OK ですよ
それはすごい知恵ですけど
まだ間違えますからね
それで時間かけてもかけてもかけても
本を読んでも読んでも
もう何年経ってもさっぱりわけられないんだったら
これはもう明らかに無知なんですね
ゆっくりデータを受け取ってから落ち着いて判断に達することは
本当は早いんです ゆっくり落ち着いて動く人々はすごく早いんです
焦っている人よりはものすごい早い
この我々言っている速さに問題がありますよ
我々いっぱい無駄をしているんだから
焦って早くやろうとしているだけで
無駄だけカットすれば
結果としてもう信じられないほど早いんです
はい これから落ち着いてから
我々はこれを大事にするんですよ
心のケアの場合は 本当は落ち着くだけでも十分です
これ何でしたっけ？論理と理性ですね
英語で言えばラショナルティということで
論理的に理論的に思考するならば
頭の妄想 無駄回転がなくなるんです
その人は何かの結論に達する
結論に至らない場合は
さらにデータを取り入れることにする
だから 論理型に理性型になるしか方法はないんですよ
理性的論理的判断は調整を
認知する いいかどうか
正しいかどうか分かりませんけど
説明します 認知するので
少々間違いは害になりません
例えば こういうことです
日本語は私にはわかりません
誰が書いたんでしょうかね
で 理性で論理的でデータ取り入れて
よく比べてみて それだったらこんなことではないのかと判断する
しかし その人 感情でした判断じゃないでしょ
だから調整利くんですよ
もう第三者からそう判断したっても
実はこういう風に見ると
こういう答えではないのかというと
あ なるほど その人はそれ納得いくんですよ
感情だったら絶対ダメです
もう聞かない だから例えば国際会議とかね
国と国との問題とか 理性的な問題だったら
論理的に立ち上がった問題だったら解決できますよ
これ感情があるんだからどうにもならないんですね
例えば イスラエル人とパレスチナ人を仲良くすることは
そんなに無理不可能なことじゃないんです
論理的に考えれば もともとパレスチナ人の国だから
こちらは後から入ったんだから
そこら辺で まあじゃあ我々はここぐらいはもう自分の国であんた方はそちらで仲良くしましょうと
それで話はつきます でもなんで話が終わらないんですか？感情
で ずっと糸口しっぱなしで
どんな国の問題であっても同じなんですよ
というわけで 感情は猛毒です
前もそのポイントは言いました
これは心には異物です
心の機能は論理的に起こるんです
すごい丁寧に これに非論理的な感情が入っちゃうと
これが猛毒なんです 脳を壊す
能力を破壊する 精神的エネルギーを浪費する
不幸に陥れる 猛毒は感情です
大体瞬時に達する知識は感情が作る代物ですよ
これ気をつけなくちゃ
瞬時に決めたら危ないんです
瞬時に決めることは感情ならできます
怒ったら殴ったとかね
ずいぶん瞬時に しかし
怒っても理性のある人だったら
殴ってはあかんだから
じゃあ怒鳴ろうかな やっぱり怒鳴ったっても
またどれもやめようかなとかね
でも悔しいと怒ったんだ
やっぱり怒ってる私が悪いんだからね
自分がもうイライラするんだから
じゃあ怒らないことにする
そうすると怒りをなくしちゃいますよ
理性型だったら それで殴ることもないし
怒鳴ることもないし 自分の怒りを収めて自分が穏やかにいる
そういうことじゃなくて
すぐ行動するならばね
必ずせっかちで 私はよく言いますよ
みんな自慢げに私はせっかちだから
こんなスローモーションとか言おうとする前に
私はせっかちな方々いますよ
大体私は心先に読みますからね
あれはもう極限に無知ですよと言うと
本人言いたかったんですけど
言えなかったんだからね
二回は来ないんです 感情が収めるまで待ちましょう
その時間は無駄ではありません
怒りやら欲やら感情が出たら
何も判断しないで待った方がいいんです
何もしないで この何もしないで待つことは無駄ではありませんよ
自分の幸福の世界ですからね
待ってる中ではその時仕事してないんではなく
大丈夫です 仕事してろくな仕事はできんでしょうね
本を読んだってろくに読めないでしょうに
だから何もしないで待つことはとてもいいことですよ
その場合  うん 感情で達した判断は変えたがらないんですからね
間違っているのに正しいと強調するんですよ
感情は 調整は利きません
自分だけではなく 他人にも多大な迷惑
不幸 損害を与えるんです
感情的な思考は悪行為だとするのです
感情的な思考はすべて悪行為なんです
悪思考なんです 悪の中で思考が一番重い罪なんです
それで我々はこういう有意義なであることを
次のケアですよ 無駄な思考をやめて
心は早く正しく働かせるため
働かすためには 自分が達する知識は有意義か否かを確かめるんです
自分のこの思考が有意義ですか？役に立ちますかと
それだけ気をつければ大量の思考が止まるんですよ
すごく速くなるんですよ
普通はもう 3時間  4時間時間かかって何かやってもらうため
あれは妄想にかかった時間なんですよ
では 仕事がある それに考えなくちゃいけない
それだったら有意義なことだけ考えれば
変な思考が入ったら これはもう意味がないんだから
カットとカットすればいいでしょう
これで見事に誰でも早くなります
人は正しく生きていれば
誰でも天才になります
有意義でないと思われる一切の思考をやめれば
普通の人より 100倍ぐらい能力が上がると思います
これも私は随分低く評価して
もう普通の人で 100倍速くなったらありがたいでしょう
無駄な思考をやめれば
有意義に思考すればたちまち速くなるんです
100倍にしたのは この完全にカットっていうのはね
まあこれはいくらなんでも人間には無理ですからね
でも極力控えることはできるでしょうね
じゃあここら辺で ちょっと休憩いたします
この魔法にかけられた破壊という自己破壊っていうのは魔法なんです
では  10 分ぐらい休憩いたします